oftentimes I talk to established actors
who are directing their first film and
they tell me that the only way they were
able to get it made and get money was to
promise to actually be in the movie -
you were able to get away with not being
in the movie how I just said I'm not
gonna be in the movie I think it was
important I you know if you know
somebody from acting you might have all
these preconceived notions of them and
it was important to me that this film
was about these kids and not about you
thinking about me in any way how long
had this idea been percolating in your
mind as a script and how long did it
take you to get it made and written well
I took me three years in 20 drafts and
what's interesting about Heidi and voilá
belt is that they I had asked them to
work on it
when I was only like ten pages into the
screenplay so wait three years before we
even started shooting they were already
the first two people and Scott Roberts
in our first ad / executive producer who
were like the people that I knew I
wanted to make the movie with
fundamentally mm-hmm and they said yes
because they're very warm generous
people hey I'd love to hear from the two
of you hiding Christopher your histories
with Jonah Christopher I know you were
the cinematographer on don't worry you
won't get far on foot which is the movie
that Jonah very recently made with Gus
Van Sant what's how far do you guys go
back what's your history well we met we
made his birthday dinner yeah it was my
wife's birthday at Musso and Frank's and
uh Jonah was there with Spike and I
didn't know Jonah yet and I had it's old
Polaroid and I was like I don't know I'm
gonna go mess with these guys and I was
walking up like as if I was gonna sell
them a picture and I already saw Jonah
like every like get rid of this guy by
like through a napkin and me anyway he
was that night he told Jonah that's
again it's gonna shoot your movie so I
was lucky enough to be on spikes good
list and then we met and he told me
about this movie yeah we took Chris
shoots Kelly records films and
chris is just a brilliant GP as you can
see from his work so I was already a
massive fan and then yeah spike is this
really funny connector in my life he's
in everybody's life he's just this
wonderful guy and he is definitely a
mentor to me and he he just when Chris
walked away he's like oh yeah I bet you
thousand bucks Chris shoots mid-90s and
I was like why does a key grew up
skating in LA and I just know I just
know and then I was like angry because I
hate when people tell me like what I'm
gonna do basically as I went home he's
wrong and I'm like look at all these
other DPS and then I thought about you
know the films that Chris is shot in
super 16 and just like even meeting him
for five minutes he's just a magical
person so I was lucky as hell that Chris
would shoot my film how about you had
you how did you guys connect well we had
mutual friends and and I would see Jonah
from time to time and then it had been a
while and I was we were at a show and I
was across the room from him and he
yelled my name and I was like I've been
looking for you and told me about the
project and of course I was thrilled and
yeah I took a minute before you know I
heard from him again with with anything
but I from that day I knew that it was
gonna happen yeah
Jonah you and I spoke about a month ago
before anyone had seen this movie we did
an interview about it and you said
something that I really remember you you
really didn't want this to be to feel
overly nostalgic about the decade it
takes place and you said you didn't want
to be that 90s movie how did you work
with these two and your department heads
all over the film to make sure that you
were feeling authentic and accurate but
not too on-the-nose with it well I think
we put a great amount of effort into
just trying whether it was Chris and I
trying to shoot things from further back
or statically and not like kind of
moving on things too overtly
and then Heidi just meticulously
choosing
each piece of clothing for each person
with like severe emotional reasons why
and I think that you know let her speak
to that more but I laugh about it
because in essence it's like a jeans and
t-shirt kind of movie and so like in
terms of costuming you know someone who
might not be keyed into that world or
what that time was about for kids like
that maybe you know it might be lost on
them but there was a great deal of
thought that went into all the costumes
from especially because of the brands
and and yeah and a lot of archive stuff
that we had to find her remake Jonah how
did you feel confident that nikhyl and
Olin could handle the acting that was
required obviously they're at the top of
their game as far as the skating is
concerned what did you do with them
audition wise to feel like these guys
can handle this I think coming up in
comedy so much of you know being around
young people in comedy when I was coming
up like so much of it is their mind or
their spirit as and then it kind of I
watched a lot of young people turn into
actors myself included like I wasn't in
a trained actor I was trained as like a
writer so to me you meet these people
and their spirits are just so vibrant
and they're so they have an inability to
be false and so I figured if they're up
for the challenge of working towards it
they will get there it's up to them
really and so a lot of times I'll just
ask them like I think you're wonderful I
think you're talented I think you're
special are you up for working
tirelessly to become an actor is that
something you're anxious even interested
in because I also just don't want to put
you in the movie and have you be blase
about it either
and both Nickell Olin gee I mean ngo
sunny ryder they all you know Chris and
I designed the movie Anna Heidi like we
were gonna have like them wired at base
camp so they're closed wired so we're
trying to protect the filmmaking process
from them but then they were so
ambitious they like we're so interested
in learning about the film process that
it was amazing you know so I was like
how do we like have them not even NOAA
cameras there how do we have them not
even know that someone is wiring their
clothing like how do we just get them to
exist and they were like calling out
like mother-daughter shots and like all
these like technical terms and it was
just like really beautiful to watch yeah
check the gate they were obsessed with
the term check the gate yeah they called
themselves to check the gate crew the
guy that plays fourth grade his name's
Ryder Chris did you work with him since
he was shooting in the movie what did
what kind of stuff did you guys talk
about yeah we he had a camera that
worked you know they were he was filming
with that camera constantly we had a
couple of them because they were old and
they would break but we had him all
propped up to match but he was
incredible and you know we'd send him
off when we were doing the lighting so
that we'd send the kids off to skate and
they would get their own footage and the
best was in the Edit like I had I was
like there's a skate video at the end of
the film like you guys have to make a
skate video so like they'd always be off
and Ryder would be filming them doing
stuff and for me it was great is I just
like had like 12 hours of footage when I
got to the editing room and I hadn't
seen any of it yeah so it's like so cool
it was like my own ending to the movie
of like oh I got to see what they were
doing with the opportunity to make
something on their own - awesome well I
congratulate all three of you on a job
well done a really great movie